nice nice nice today we start selling on
the great British High Street for the
first time but there's yet another
hurdle before I can deliver all this
stuff to my papa bakery so where are we
gonna get an x-ray
Jimmy x-ray an x-ray at our what happens
if we've lost a nut or a bolt and it's
fallen in one of these Jesus and can we
just forget about that for now or do we
have to go on are we don't we're doing
it properly in true yeah now but there's
no nuts involved here at the end of the
day we don't have one of our majesty's
prisons we have systems that we have to
go by no matter who is for we do not
change the system it's for anybody else
down was that trolley nearby just coming
dawn thank you pizza boxes so all the
[ __ ] work has gone in so it's time to
make my escape aided and abetted by
prison head chef my accomplice dal
Hatfield
I'll be brilliant this is crazy another
this is absolutely ludicrous check
there's no vault and nuts and guns in
doubt then to LA show some flexibility
go to the supermarket is bad enough but
[ __ ] me this is ridiculous
this takes the biscuit and if every
single que contar de has to be x-rayed
I'm going through to
morning and we are going to be telling
them everything you buy here has been
made by prisoners okay so the bad boys
bakery is born lemon curd for me growing
up with all that little bill mmm luxury
and it tastes delicious
so first up at classic with a twist
lemon curd treacle tarts